vous êtes sûr que que Karim Benzema a un
lien avec les Frères musulmans est-ce
qu'il y a des preuves est-ce qu'il y a
des choses ou pas bah écoutez moi je
suis pas ministre de l'Intérieur je ne
suis pas enquêteur et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai interrogé le le
ministre de l'Intérieur et je lui ai
demandé alors où en est-on qu'est-ce qui
se
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
passe ce soir on pense à tous les
professeurs qui revoient cette scène
encore tous les instituteurs tous les
professeurs tout le corps enseignant qui
doit se dire parce qu'il se
reconnaissent dans Dominique Bernard qui
est un héros aujourd'hui parce que s'il
avait pas si c'était pas interposé ça
aurait été beaucoup plus dramatique et
ça aurait été un carnage c'est un héros
aujourd'hui Antoine je voudrais te
remercier d'être avec nous aujourd'hui
tu as qu tu as quel âge Antoine j'ai 27
ans 27 ans tu es un ancien élève de
Dominique Bernard oui je suis très
content que tu sois là ce soir parce que
Dominique Bernard est un héros c'était
ton professeur combien d'années tu l'as
eu en je l'ai eu euh 3 ans durant le
collège donc les tris les trois
dernières années du collège donc 5e 4e
et 3e ouais donc il y a maintenant quasi
15 ans c'est ça voilà de 2007 à 2011 à
peu près voilà et et je je tu as
vraiment quand on t'a demandé de venir
t' as dit oui tout de suite pourquoi cé
un professeur que que tu aimais beaucoup
bah c'est-à-dire que si je devais
ressortir un professeur de ma scolarité
c'est lui je pense je pense qu'on a tous
un ou plusieurs professeurs qui nous
reste en tête même quand on a 60 70 ans
et euh bah je je pense que j'aurais
sorti son nom euh si on m'avait demandé
voilà pourquoi parce qu'il était déjà
passionné ça c'est sûr euh gentil avec
les élèves euh et il avait une qualité
qu'on demande pas forcément dans un
premier temps à un professeur mais en
plus de ça il était drôle ouais donc en
fait ce qu'il avait du mal à faire
passer il le faisait passer par l'humour
que ça soit en cours ou ou à l'extérieur
euh toujours une petite blague quand on
le croisait en dehors du lycée ou dans
les couloirs donc voilà c'est ce qui m'a
marqué aujourd'hui il a sauvé des
vies Dominique Bernard ça lui a coûté sa
vie d'ailleurs euh quand vous avez
appris sa mort je pense que vous étiez
dévasté bah quand déjà j'ai lu
professeur de lettres abattu au collège
Gambetta et la première chose à laquelle
j'ai enfin j'ai pensé c'est Monsieur
Bernard parce que je me suis dit que
s'il y avait bien un prof qui enin qui
aurait voulu raisonner l'assaillant
c'est vrai c'était lui ah ouais donc
donc je me suis dit c'est Monsieur
Bernard et une heure après je lis les
articles et je vois Monsieur Bernard
abattu il essayait toujours de trouver
des des solutions de de de toujours
c'était bah un accompagnateur vraiment
et exactement comme je vous dis en cours
comme comme en dehors de toute façon
toujours une petite blague je toujours
le sourire voilà vous avez ressenti quoi
quand vous avez appris que c'était lui
bah bouleverser clairement bouleversé je
pense qu'il y a pas d'autres mots bien
sûr voilà il y a pas d'aut autre mot
c'est c'est c'est c'est fou parce que
quand quand vous nous racontez tout ça
alors bien sûr quoi qu'il arrive c'est
c'est un c'est c'est dramatique et là on
on quand on connaît encore plus le le le
personnage qui s'est trouvé euh à à
sauveré des des vies à cause de de de de
ce terroriste on se dit c'est c'est on
est on on est encore plus triste ce soir
de de de dans votre témoignage euh c'est
c'est Gilles c'est c'est c'est F
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé exactement ben
vous avez raison parce que s'il ne
s'interpose pas il y a eu il y a eu en
plus de lui il y a eu les agents de
sécurité un autre professeur blessé mais
sil ne s'interpose pas au début
peut-être que les élèves n'ont pas le
temps de se confiner et en fait ça
rejoint ce que ce que Antoine nous dit
c'est-à-dire que tout de suite il s'est
dit peut-être je vais au sacrifice mais
je vais protéger les élèves il leur a
dit courz allez vous confiner allez vous
protéger parce que la configuration de
l'établissement fait que l'agresseur
aurait pu être face à des élèves donc
c'est vraiment un héros qui a sauvé des
vies par sa bravoure extrême donc il
avait 57 ans il était professeur de
lettrre il était père de trois filles
ouais ilu d'une famille d'enseignant et
il était marié à une professeur
d'anglais euh vous avez dit que c'est le
professeur qui vous avez le plus marqué
dans votre scolarité
euh quel est le le voilà le le fait qui
vous a le plus marqué quand vous étiez
avec j'ai pas forcément d'anecdote si
j'ai un souvenir c'est vraiment toujours
son sourire la bonne humeur bon parfois
on n pas forcément envie d'aller en
cours et cetera mais euh par exemple si
c'était un peu le bazar dans les
couloirs euh avec un autre prof
peut-être que ça aurait continué
Monsieur Bernard est sortait de sa
classe ouais et ça se cal mais j'ai
d'ailleurs vu une enfin un témoignage
d'une d'une professeur du même lycée
sur les réseaux sociaux qui disait qui
enfin qui a raconté cette anecdote et
c'était exactement ça quand les élèves
le voyaient ont changé presque de
comportement par rapport à un
prof un peu plus banal on va dire entre
guillemets il était vraiment pas banal
en fait c'est monsieur tout le monde il
a un nom assez banal mais c'était pas
monsieur tout le monde c'est ça voilà
mais déjà je pense que c'est lui qui a
été à la rencontre de de de de ce
terroriste et c'est vrai que c'est fou
ce que vous nous avez dit a un instant
vous nous avez dit s'il y a une personne
dans le lycée qui allit aller à la
rencontre de cette de cet assaillant
pour le raisonner c'était lui exactement
c'est ça donc je quand j'ai lu les
titres je me suis dit ça ne peut être
que lui prof de lettre en plus bien sûr
donc bah ça n'a pas raté quand
euh quel quel étaé le sentiment parce
que nous nous voilà je vous dis on est
on était tous en colère Antoine
forcément il y a de la tristesse énorme
mais après on a une colère immense je
pense que Géraldine d'accord avec moi
Gill on on est tous he on est tous on se
dit mais comment ça peut arriver à une
personne qui est sans problème qui est
là pour au contraire former les élèves
pour apprendre pour pour donner son
savoir pour apprendre qui fait un métier
exceptionnel qui est un professeur
exceptionnel tout le monde le disait
voilà Antoine nous le confirme encore ce
soir et il se
retrouve au milieu voilà d'un d'un d'un
truc qui qui ne qui qui qui ne le
concerne pas et aujourd'hui on lu a ôté
sa vie on a ôté sa vie et on a ôté on a
on a on a bousillé une famille on a
bousillé je suis sûr que les élèves
aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué de
retourner à l'école et surtout c'est
comme il l'a dit Antoine aujourd'hui
aussi on a eu plein de témoignages
d'élèves qui disent que c'est un
professeur exceptionnel et que quand on
allait suivre ces cours c'était c'était
un bonheur je sais que voilà c'est ce
que tu nous confimes 15 ans après
tous les témoignages que j'ai c'est
exactement toutes les petites anecdotes
c'est exactement ce que moi j'ai vécu
c'est ça donc voilà j'ai même j'ai même
plusieurs amis que je n'ai pas forcément
vu depuis le collège quand on a appris
la nouvelle il m'ont envoyé un message
on c'était peut-être pas parlé depuis 10
ans ouis tu as vu c'est Monsieur Bernard
comme si on avait pas arrêté de se
parler en fait
donc vous avez été triste en colère vous
avez été comment bah c'est quand quand
une personne aussi belle entre
guillemets décède sous les coups d'un
d'un malade ouais c'est quand même
difficile de passéder à la haine on va
dire ouais c'est ça exactement moi je me
mets surtout à la place des familles
enfin trois filles c'est ça moi je pense
à sa famille aujourd'hui on des compte
les trois filles qu compte ça sa femme
Gilles ça c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
il part le matin comment tu peux te
c'est une famille brisée bien sûr sûr
lui lui il part pour aller en cours et
puis il y a ce ce Mohamed mogutchov
moukov on va donner son nom qui tu peut
donner son nom qui le tue voilà alors
sans doute en plus éétait prémédité il
voulait tuer un prof voilà tuer le
symbole du professeur c'est ça qui est
Terri pourquoiir alors pour le moment et
ben pour le moment il ne parle pas
beaucoup en garde à vue encore jusqu'à
demain matin demain midi il en garde à
vue il ne dit pas ses motivations ne
sait pas il provoque un peu sur lesffet
il ne revient pas beaucoup donc on ne
sait pas
pourquoi moiavais dit ici moi j'avais
dit ici que Samuel paatti fallait en
faire un héros je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez j'avais dit qu'il fallait tout
de
suite oui mais alorsoui il y a 3 ans
j'avais dit faut faire tout de suite une
école SAMU la famille des victimes elle
en a marre d'avoir des héros vrai parce
que c'est facile après d'aller sur les
chaînes infos et dire vous ne savez on
baissera pas les bras on regardera dans
les yeux on on n pas peur de vous ok
mais en attendant vous avez fait quoi
pour sa paatti un rond-point une rue une
école que dal rien il est mort pour rien
et là on recommence encore on a un autre
professeur qui qui se fait encore
égorger dans son collège dans son lycée
on a les images vous voulez en faire
quoi de ce mec qui tape des mecs au sol
ils essayent de se défendre il sort d'où
ce mec il sort de nulle part on en fait
quoi moi je veux pas faire de justice on
va pas se substituer à la justice vous
voulez en faire quoi lui dire devant un
tribunal tu sais pas bien ce que tu as
fait hein bon allez 10 ans en prison et
après on verra non non les mecs arrêtez
on arrête d'être gentil maintenant ça
suffit on arrête les conneries les mecs
il viennent pour nous apprendre moi mon
plus gros regret c'est d'avoir arrêté
l'école à 14 ans j'ai pas j'ai pas
profité des profs les profs c'est ce
qu'il y a de plus beau donc laissez les
envie arrêtez on arrête 2 minutes
d'égorger des profs Samuel pati on a
rien fait même pas une école il y a
aucun responsable politique qui a eu le
courage de dire on va faire une école
Samuel pti peu importe la ville on va en
faire aucun je m'en fous des menaces
alors faut pas dire on baisse pas les
yeux tu as baissé les yeux tu baissé les
yeux d' je suis d'accord mais que les
politiques ne viennent pas comme j'ai
vu professeur on pe
pas ils ont peur alors qu'ils disent pas
on baisse pas les yeux qui disent on
baisse lesux à place des professeurs
aussi Fautre à place je parle des
politique je parle pas des professeurs
les professur ils ont un courage
incroyable moi je suis prof il arrive ça
je vais même plus en cours remercier
d'être venu nous voir vraiment et c'est
important pour nous d'avoir ton
témoignage et on pense tous bien sûr
très fort comme tu l'as dit à à la
famille j'aimerais juste professeur
justement que j'ai eu donc un professeur
de mathématiques que j'ai eu au collège
monsieur Lourdel que j'ai vu témoigner
et qui a eu exactement la même la même
description que tous et monsieur verag
qui a directement été touché puisque
c'est le prof de PS qui exactement que
j'ai eu également en cours voilà merci
cé important de d'avoir Antoine ce soir
on pense bien sûr à toute la famille de
Dominique
Bernard euh on a on a malheureusement
nos réponses et elles sont tristes je va
commencer par la fin c'est c'est-à-dire
le 12 jeudi dernier
euh ça se passe dans un tout petit
village qui s'appelle corsel en
Beaugelet il y a une maison un peu
abandonnée un corps de ferme et le
propriétaire plus précisément le fils du
propriétaire arrive ce jour-là dans
l'après-midi avec des artisans pour
envisager de faire un un un chantier
enfin de faire une rénovation de ce
bâtiment et il pénètre à l'intérieur du
bâtiment et découvre dans une pièce dans
la pénombre il distingue un corps des
chaussures et immédiatement il sort
prévient les gendarmes qui arrivent sur
place et après avoir fait leur travail
de constatation s'aperçoivent que c'est
très très probablement à 99,9 % Marwan
berenny tout ça parce qu'il y a une
d'abord parce qu' on est à 3 ou 4 km de
l'endroit où il avait abandonné sa
voiture donc là c'est fleurri le long
d'un champ de vigne euh il a dû couper à
travers les vignes pour rejoindre
corcell et les gendarmes découvrent une
banane dans laquelle se trouve permis de
conduire carte d'identité et d'autres
documents qui au nom donc de Marwan
Beren et tout ça a commencé le 3 août
aux alentours de enfin pas aux alentours
à
23h10 Marwan Beren était dans une boîte
de nuit qui s'appelle le 400 le club 400
à Macon il est pas resté longtemps ce
soir là il était tout seul il a bu un
verre il a eu deux appels téléphoniques
il resté une demi-heure et ensuite il
est ressorti on l'a en vidéo
surveillance à 11h5 23h05 eu il il monte
dans cette voiture ce fameux 4x4
Mercedes il démarre sur les chapeaux de
roues et au même moment une jeune femme
de 37 ans traverse dans les passages
protégés les passages clouté euh
elle est avec son chien et elle est
littéralement percuté par le véhicule
qui n'a pas freiné et qui ne s'est
surtout pas arrêté et à partir de là on
on on sait pas très bien ce qu'il a fait
je pense qu'il il a dû rentrer dormir
chez lui il habitait à
Fuissé le lendemain on sait par sa carte
bleue qu'il a utilisé dans une
boulangerie je crois à 15h et il aurait
passé un appel téléphonique à
13h38 c'est les derniers signes de vie
qu'on a de Marwan Beren ensuite il se
vol latilise le 5 août donc 2 jours
après on retrouve la Mercedes sur le
bord de de la route et le 12 donc jeudi
dernier on retrouve mais il y a plein de
questions parce que qu'on que doivent se
poser les les téléspectateur également
comment il s'est retrouvé dans dans
cette maison c'était une maison
abandonnée comment il s'est retrouvé là
on comprend pas ça on sait pas il y a un
couple qui témoigne et qui dit l'avoir
vu Erer au lendemain dans les dans les
vignes autour donc est-ce qu'il s'est
déplacé à pied c'est à k de là voit voit
voilà est-ce qu'il est parti à pied vers
cette maison et dans un geste de
désespoir voilà là pour le moment on
ignore mais mais mais ce qu'on comprend
pas et chez vous on va on va reprendre
l'affaire c'està-dire que il percute
cette jeune fille donc en boîte de nuit
donc derrière en sortant de boîte de
nuit le soir là il prend sa voiture
et pourquoi il met fin à ses jours alors
qu'il a dû avoir des nouvelles comme
quoi cette jeune fille quelques jours
après all est voilà elle était blessée
mais voilà elle s'en était sortie c'est
ça c'est ça qu'on comprend
pas on comprend pas en fait non non je
je pense pas qu'il est au moment où bah
il a été à la boulangerie donc un moment
ou non mais c'est c'est le lendemain
matin et lendemain matin si lendemain
matin on savait si si si bah si le
lendemain matin lendemain matin je suis
désolé vous savez si une personne est
décédée ou pas si vous l'avez si vous
l'avez percuté en tout cas elle était
dans le comma ses jours était elle était
en pronostic vit à
l'engager fort aussi he bien bien sûr
euh donc je pense que c'est pas aussi
simple que ça et et je pense qu'il a
euh de toute façon ça devait enfit c'est
c'est très compliqué de commenter un
suicide de de de c'est quelquefois même
un peu indécent donc moi ça me enfin ça
me dérange mais il c'est jamais une
cause unique un suicide euh donc il y a
l'accident on sait aussi qu'il y avait
son son frère c'était un peu la date
anniversaire de la mort de son frère
Bilal qui lui a été assassiné à D3 aux
États-Unis en
2013 d'accord mais si vous le
connaissiez bien moi je le connaissais
bien ouais je le connaissais bien
j'avais passé on a été très proche
pendant quelques moisà on a eu on a eu
une histoire et puis ça faisait quand
même des années que je l'avais pas vu
j'avais toujours de ces nouvelles parce
qu'on a des amis en commun et et voilà
c'était c'était un super garçon c'est un
c un artiste justement comment après
avoir percuté cette jeun fille il il
peut partir et dire
parce que c'est c'est extrêmement
violent il se serait pendu c'est ça g
oui c'est ça oui oui absolument le le le
corps qui a été retrouvé é été retrouvé
pendu avec des papiers à son nom donc
voilà il y a une autopsie mais voilà
c'est à 99 % lui hélas et sans
doute ne pas pouvoir accepter ce qu'il
vient de faire en se disant j'ai commis
l'irréparable j'ai commis un acte
horrible c'est insupportable pour moi et
donc voilà je je ma ma vie est ma vie
est fichu j'ai brisé une vie peut-être
et et je ne peux plus m'accepter comme
ça parce que tout à l'heure je vous
voyez me faire des signes vous me disiez
il savait pas qu'il savait pas le
lendemain quand il va à la boulangerie
qu'on
allait quoi mais non le lendemain en
fait la la la jeune femme Sandra elle
est en réanimation et on sait pas si de
quelle manière elle va s'en sortir en
fait et quand il a ce ce dernier appel à
13h38 on sait toujours pas si si sandra
est vivante si Sandra bah voilà dans
quel état all est et et je sais que à
13h38 il le dit je sais pas si c'est un
truc que je dois dire mais il le dit la
seule chose qui me reste à faire c'est
partir quoi donc il le dit à
13h38 derni derni Rael c'est des choses
qui m'ont été répété donc j'ai pas je
peux rien vous à qui il donne son
dernier Rael on peut pas savoir sa pas
voilà donc c'est le dernier appel qu'il
donne et dans son dernier appel à priori
il dirait la seule chose qu' me reste à
faire c'estette partir donc c'est
vraiment suite à à cet accident que il
décide de de de mettre fin à ces jour
mais je parle en son nom mais Marwan il
vivait avec la culpabilité de la mort de
son frère même s'il y est pour rien mais
en fait ne pas réussi enfin ne pas avoir
réussi à protéger son petit frère enfin
je pense que c'était c'était déjà inviva
pour lui c'était quelqu'un de torturé
quelqu'un de tourmenté quelqu c'était il
vivait sans limite moi c'était pour moi
c'était un artiste qui était beaucoup
plus intelligent que tout le monde et je
pense que personne pouvait être dans son
cerveau et là le fait d'avoir bah voilà
renversé quelqu'un je pense que c'était
bah c'était la petite goutte d'eau qui
qui qui a fait déborder qui a fait
déborder une grosse goutte d'eau oui et
oui G la mort de son frère est
fondamentale Cyril pour pour comprendre
le on va appeler on va rappeler pour
téléspectateurs il s'appelit comment son
joaim son frère son son frère c'était
Bilal ou un graffeur Bilal voilà très
connu qui notamment avait fait des
grafes au moment du du printemps arabe
et et pour célébrer les martyres à Tunis
et qui qui qui était connu dans le
milieu du Graf voilà il est à D3 aux
États-Unis et là il est pris à parti par
trois personnes qui le tue d'une balle
dans la tête ces trois personnes avaient
des dettes et voulaient le dévaliser lui
ont pris 200 ou 300 € sans le connaître
il était près d'un terrain de basket ils
l'ont tué sauvagement et le au-delà du
pire du pire c'est que son corps a mis 8
mois à être identifié pendant 8 mois il
a disparu on ne savait pas que c'était
lui donc du coup ça a été voilà pour lui
un un un drame épouvantable et c'est
vrai qu'il y avait une certaine
fragilité mais mais mais c'est normal
c'est tellement épouvantable ce drame
que que il voilà il avait vraiment du
mal c'est impossible de digérer ça mais
pour lui c'était très très dur mais vous
avez dit qu' qu'il avait peut-être été
vu en Suisse alors c'est ça parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens qui ont réagi ce
week on g ditit qu'il était en Suisse
alors que pas du toutou voilà alors ça
donc ce qu'il faut dire c'est que nous
quand on couvre des des des faits divers
et des enquêtes on avance au rythme de
l'enquête d'accord et un média
extrêmement crédible qui jusque là vu
toutes les bonnes informations a révélé
cette piste Suisse qui a été reprise par
d'autres médias moi j'ai travaillé avec
ce média puis j'ai vérifié et à ce
moment-là quand on en a pas parler ici
il y avait l'hypothèse de cette piste
Suisse sur laquelle la police
travaillait voilà hypothèse qui n'est
donc pas avérée je ne cite pas le média
en question je vais en prendre la
responsabilitéord merci bravo g voilà
hypothèse qui ne s'est pas avéré mais
qui était à l'époque jugé extrêmement
crédible par la police voilà
alors Michel donc l'histoire donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé parce que il a on l'a pas retrouvé
pendant des jours et des
jours oui c'est ça qu'on a envie de
savoir parce qu'on comprend c'est ça
qu'on comprend racontez-nous pendant 2
mois on sait pas où il est donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé la police
était chargée de l'enquête et ils ont
été à son domicile ils ont convoqué un
certain nombre de de proches de Marwan
pour essayer de savoir s'ils avaient des
nouvelles ils ont essayé de remonter
aussi les la téléphonie mais en même
temps il il pouvait pas fouiller toutes
les maisons à 10 15 km aux alentours de
de son domicile ils sont donc en réalité
si le fils du propriétaire était pas
venu ce jour-là pour faire faire des des
devis avec les artisans je pense qu'on
aurait toujours pas retrouvé le le corps
de Marwan Beren alors et les enquêteurs
ont mis longtemps à démarrer en plus
hein au début il pensaient au-delà de ça
oui tu as raison mais au-delà de ça
techniquement c'est impossible qu'il
fouille toutes les maisons c'est pas
c'est pasou mais ce qui frappe Michel
c'est 5 km 6 km donc on se dit quand
même quelqu'un disparaît on peut faire
des cercles concentriques et voà il est
daté à quand son DESS bah c'est ça oui
il est daté on essa pas ça pas la date
mais enfin sans vouloir rentrer dans les
détails c'était à mon avis très proche
vu le l'état du corps c'était donc très
proche de de sa disparition très vite
après son dernier coup je pense
hnêtement que il a abandonné sa voiture
il a traverser les vignes à pied il est
rentré dans ce bâtiment est-ce qu'il le
connaissait est-ce qu'il est rentré par
par hasard trouver une maison abandonnée
c'est compliqué conna et donc c'était
quoi et donc après et là il se pend
c'est c'est fou donc c'est donc en fait
donc il a jamais fu en fait il pas
supporté avait
fait CAV apréori on on on dirait avec
des des des des bien sûr avec des
conditionne ce serait vraiment juste le
lendemain c'est ça de de de de laffire
comme vous le disiez il y a un instant
donc dernier coup de fil à 13h38 et
derrière le le le drame Fiona il y a
datani marké qui é avec nous qui était
avec avec lui en vacances quelques jours
avant le le drame qui et il lui avait
dit moi si un jour je renverse quelqu'un
je me foutrai en l'air je ne le
supporterai pas et je ne veux pas avoir
ça sur ma conscience bah moi vous savez
c'est c'est paradoxal avec le petit
message qu'il avait laissé à 13h30 mais
moi j'étais persuadée j'aurais mis ma
main à couperé que ce soirl que j'ai
rencontré
Marwan j'aurais mis ma main à coupé que
que qu'il avait fui et que on l'aurait
retrouvé dans 5 ans 10 ans dans j'aurais
jamais pu imaginer qu'il mette fin un sé
jour et quand je lis la lettre de ses
parents le 3 octobre si je su pas de
bêtises euh je pense que ses parents
étaient incapables de s'imaginer qu'il
pourrait qu'il pourrait faire une chose
pareille mais moi je croyais j'étais
franchement c'est c'est inimaginable et
enfin c'est horrible quoi les les deux
vous avez dit qu' il a passé un dernier
coup de à 138 et il a annoncé M rien oua
oui oui mais entre annoncer et le faire
vous savez Cyril je sais bah bien sûr
non non mais c'est
sûr que vous avez entendu le le premier
coup de feu ben quand j'ai entendu le
premier coup de fin en fait c'est j'ai
arrivais juste pas j'ai pas j'ai trop
pris ça en fait à la légère je me suis
dit écoute c'est rien c'est soit des
pétards soit soit quelque chose vous
étiez où j'étais juste à en face de
l'immeuble à côté exement c'est ça c'est
vraiment un témoin c'est un un des
témoins le plus proche qu' avait hier
Suleiman et donc premier coup de feu
vous dites non sa rien non sa rien et en
fait j'ai trop pris ça à la légère je me
suis dit écoute j'ai l'habitude
d'entendre des des bruits comme ça mais
c'est des pétards et tout ça mais après
j'ai vu du coup ces deux couples là qu
étaient en train de en train de fuir et
je trouvais ça en fait justement bizarre
j'ai il court comme ça et je voisis
chaque voiture en fait qui arrivait elle
accélérait direct et c'est de là ben que
j'ai vu la entendu des cris ou des cris
des gens qui criaient dégagé des gens
j'ai entendu des des femmes qui criaient
je me suis dit c'est pas des cris normal
en fait et de là j'ai commencé quand
même à avoir un peu peur pour moi c'est
de là que j'ai vu du coup laassayon qui
est juste là qui est vous rentré par
l'immeuble qui est juste là c'est ça
vous vous l'avez vu vous avez tout de
suite compris ce qui se passait ou pas
du tout après non pas vraiment mais
quand il a tiré sur le monsieur et que
le monsieur je l'ai vu tomber en fait
ben je suis juste resté figé sur place
ça j'ai pas réussi a bougé ni euh en
fait c'est comme si le temps s'est
arrêté mais je voyais en fait ce qui
s'est passé mais j'arrivais pas à bouger
j'étais juste choqué et il y a eu du
coup il a encore continué à tirer et je
le regardais je le regardais faire en
fait et vous étiez seul mais c'est c'est
juste en fait que j'arrivais pas à
bouger j'arrivais pas à courir et il y a
eu un monsieur qui est venu chez moi qui
m'a qui m'a poussé qui m'a dit dégage
cours si tu as envie de rester en vie
cours ah ouais et de là l'assillon est
sorti il a pris il a pris la fuite moi
j'ai j'ai couru j'ai contourné pour
essayer de rentrer chez moi parce que
c'est quand même dans la rueelle d'Ar
vers vers chez moi à iszer et de là la
police est arrivée ils avaient quand
même fermé tous les rues je pouvais pas
passer je j'ai pu rentrer chez moi qu'à
3h du matin mais ça c'est une image qui
doit être dans votre tête quand même oui
j'ai pas réussi à dormir jusqu'à
maintenant je suis encore en nu blanche
j' AZ vous avez eu peur vous avez cru
qu'il allait vous tirer dessus un moment
est-ce que vous êtes dit vous avez peur
pour votre vie personnellement je me
suis dit que c'était que c'était fini en
fait que c'était c'était le moment je me
suis dit c'est bon vous avez pensé à
quoi je pensais à tout en fait ça a
remonté beaucoup des souvenirs vous avez
quel âge 20 ans 20 ans 20 ça a remonté
beaucoup de souvenirs que ça soit dans
mon pays natal en Guinée que que ça soit
ce qui s'est passé en 2015 en 2016
partout en fait il y a eu beaucoup de
souvenirs qui sont reven dans ma comis
un attentat terroriste tout de suite ou
pas du tout non non je j'ai entend quel
moment à quel moment vous l'avez compris
quand en fait j'ai entendu beaucoup des
gens dire que les médias sont venus me
parler avant pendant toute la séquence
vous dit c'est voilà
c'est c'est juste une personne qui a
essayé de cambrioler ou je sais Paso
vous avez vu son arme pardon vous avez
vu son arme non je l'ai vu tirer et vous
il il était positionné comme ça comme
comme là dans la vidéo on peut pas le
voir son arme il est positionné comme ça
et il tire et quand il tire tu vois
juste en fait la personne tomber et
quand je sais pas comment d'autres
personnes on réagi à ma place mais moi
je savais juste pas quoi faire et
j'étais choqué et juste même quand je
suis rentré chez moi j'ai eu des
policiers qui m'ont accompagné jusque
devant la porte vous avvez vous sûr vous
aviez même pas la force de parler de
crier nonen j'ai j'ai rien fait en fait
et quand je suis rentré chez moi j'ai
essayé de dormir mais à chaque fois
quand je fermais les yeux je revoyais en
fait encore cette personne tomber tomber
par terre et je suis juste resté comme
ça à rien faire et com j'ai des amis que
j'ai contacté qui m'ont m aidé qui m'ont
parlé ça doit être un un traumatisme éom
quand même oui parce que je me dis
comment je vais faire maintenant j'ai du
mal souvent déjà que j'avais déjà du mal
à me concentrer ben là c'est encore là
c'est encore plus mais c'est que je
trouve vraiment aussi triste dans tout
ça c'est qu'on est obligé de se
justifier nous les musulmans je dire
c'est voui on est obligé de se justifier
alors que moi j'ai envie de dire en fait
on na pas se justifié pour un acte
barbare que un fou a fait tout à fait
qui ne représente pas la communauté qui
ne représente pas l'islam il ne
représente pas mais qui se représente
que lui-même bravo s bravo Suan bravo su
bravo Suan c'est important de le dire
c'est très important de le dire Suleiman
pourquoi tu tu quand tu dis tu es obligé
de te justifier tu tu ressens quoi en ce
moment je ressens en fait que c'est
qu'on va encore nous coller des
étiquettes c'est ça et des des
étiquettes ont déjà commencé qu'on
essaie déjà de luiter qu'on essaie déjà
de montrer qu'on n'est pas tous comme ça
qu'on essaie de montrer en fait c'est
quoi vraiment la religion c'est quoi
quand vous te dis vous n'êtes pas tous
comme ça non mais c'est 99,9 % des
musulmans qui sont pas comme ça oui et
et je vais te dire et les 99,9 % des
musulmans qui voient ce qui se passe
actuellement et hier notamment et ce qui
s'est passé vendredi ça alors on est
tous peinés mais je crois qu'ils sont
encore plus peinésou que nous parce que
je vous jure moi j'ai voilà tout le
monde je les vois ils sont dévastés et
ils ont encore plus plus de haine que
nous parce qu'ils disent ça ça ça fait
mal bien sûr ils ont ils ont de la peine
pour les les victimes pour les familles
des victimes et ils ont mal aussi pour
eux parce qu'ils me disent ils me disent
souvent il va encore avoir de l'amalgame
on va encore devoir se justifier comme
tu dis et c'est vrai que toi hier tu es
témoins de cette tue tu es le principal
témoin de cette
acte de terrorisme qui est un acte
encore de voir quelqu'un pointer une
arme et tu vois les les deux personnes
tomber à terre ça c'est une image qui va
te suivre toute ta vie et derrière tu as
pas non plus envie en plus de te
justifier de raser les murs de de de de
d'être d'être d'être dans des postures
voilà de de de de défense parce que toi
tu es tu en as marre de ça oui
effectivement ça fait mal ça ça me fait
mal parce que différents personne en
fait je vois notamment si j'ai quitté
mon pays c'est pas parce qu'il faisait
moche c'est pas parce que c'est pas
parce que c'était pas beau c'est juste
parce qu'on voyait pas de l'avenir dans
notre pays on est venu dans ce pays pour
essayer de trouver la sécurité pour se
créer un avenir mais malheureusement on
ne voit pas cette sécurité je je vais te
dire un truc Souleiman qui rejoint ce
que tu dis hier j'ai encore eu beaucoup
de potes musulmans qui m'ont tenu au
courant de ce qui se passait et ils
m'écrivent pendant l'émission à 19h45 et
ils me disent apparemment il y a une
tuerie à Bruxelles et ils me disent non
c'est peut-être un règlement de compte
et cetera et après tous m'ont écrit et
non merde c'est encore plus grave c'est
un terroriste et ils étaient tous
dégoûtés voilà ils étaient tous au fond
du trou au fond du trou parce qu'ils
disent pour nous c'est la double
peine non seulement il se passe ce drame
et forcément ça angoisse tout le monde
ça stresse tout le monde ça c'est c'est
des c'est on se dit c'est des vies
humaines de de d'innocents qui se
retrouvent qui qui vont laisser des
familles entières alors qu'il venaient
je gentiment voir un match de foot et et
la double peine c'est ce qu'il me disent
à chaque fois ça va nous retomber dessus
ils me disent à chaque fois ça va nous
retomber dessus voilà ce qu'il me disent
et ça je vais pas encore revenir sur eux
mais ça enfin si je vais revenir sur eux
d'ailleurs la LFI en faisant ce qu'ils
font quand ils différencient pas le
Hamas un mouvement terroriste des
Palestiniens et du peuple palestinien il
contribuent à cet amalgame absolument
et je le dis ils ont une responsabilité
et ils devont rondre des compes parce
que là c'est bien gentil de faire les
malins sur les plateaux de télé et de
dire n'importe quoi et de se faire
remarquer mais à un moment là on joue
avec des choses assez graves même très
graves on joue avec des vies humaines et
ton ton témoignage aujourd'hui souiman
je pensais pas que tu allais me parler
de ça euh vraiment je pensais pas que tu
allais me parler de ça Suleiman je
pensais vraiment que tu étais venu juste
pour témoigner et je trouve que c'est
aussi important que ton témoignage ce
que tu dis ce soirit c'est que il y a
pas que ça en fait il y a beaucoup de
des choses qui se qui se passent même
avant ce qui est arrivé hier notamment
la sécurité des peuples mais la sécurité
des jeunes la sécurité dans les écoles
partout en fait il y a tout ça en fait
qui joue en nous et on se demande en
fait demain ça va être quoi encore
qu'est-ce qu'on va vivre encore demain
qu'est-ce qui va se passer encore demain
qu'est-ce qu'on va encore enendurer
demain comment on va réaliser ça comment
on va garantir la sécurité des jeunes
comment on va garantir garantir la
sécurité du peuple en fait et c'est de
là on se dit en fait moi personnellement
je reconnais plus dans le monde où je
vis je je ne vois plus cette solidarité
je je ne vois plus rien Souleiman
cette cette réflexion tu l'as eu
certainement depuis depuis quelques
jours et hier il se trouve en plus que
tu es
témoins de de de de cette tuerie tu nous
as dit tout à l'heure j'ai eu
l'impression que c'était le moment pour
moi est-ce que tu tu t'es dit c'est
bizarrece que j'ai l'impression que tu
te posais beaucoup de questions avant
cette tue il se trouve que tu es
là témoin principal de de de de de ce
drame et tu t'es dit c'est peut-être le
moment pour moi de partir
ouais je me suis dit en fait
c'était que parce que quand j'ai vu en
fait tous ces gens courir mais surtout
quand j'ai vu ce ce monsieur tomber en
fait et tout en fait tout a com quand
tout ça a commencé que j'ai vu ce
monsieur tomber je me dis et qu'il était
juste en fait quand il est sorti je suis
juste en fait en face de lui du coup il
est il aurait pu venir juste vers moi et
ça aurait pu être à mon tour ça aurait
pu être moi qui aura pu être dans ce
dans cet immeuble ça aurait pu être
n'importe qui en fait et je me dis en
fait comment je peux faire en fait que
quand ça va se reproduire si ça se
reproduit en fait comment je vais faire
pour éviter tout ça et c'est notamment
beaucoup de questions que je me pose sur
ça aujourd'hui tu es dans quel
état encore beaucoup de stress j'en
tremble encore tu m j'essaie plus donc
de communiquer tu fais quoi dans la vie
Souleiman VI j'étudie la science
politique et j'ai fait beaucoup de
stages et notamment mon rêve est
toujours de aider la jeunesse aider les
jeunes en difficulté montrer à ces
jeunes c'est c'est en fait de pouvoir
dire à cette jeunesse c'est VI tes rêves
et ne rêve pas ta vie tout
simplement avz demandé la déchiance de
nationalité de Karim Benzema pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi vous êtes allé aussi
loin pourquoi j'ai dit que si les propos
de Gérald daranin était
avéré s'ils avaient la gravité qui il
disait ce matin s'il avait des éléments
à ce moment-là il fallait aller plus
loin parce qu'aujourd'hui vous l'avez
dit j'aiécouté votre émission en
arrivant effectivement on on ne parle
que de ce conflit
abominable qui fait suite au plus grand
pogrom qu'on est connu depuis la deuxème
guerre mondiale parce qu'il y a jamais
eu autant de juifs tués que depuis le 7
octobre et qu'aujourd'hui et bien on a
la situation que nous connaissons en
Israël et dans la bande de de Gaza qui
affecte tout le monde je me permets
juste et je répondrai précisément à
votre question de vous dire que hélas
c'est pas le seul conflit qui endeuille
notre planète aujourd'hui puisque nous
assistons à une sorte
de les dictatures contre les démocratie
qui se passe ça se passe en Israël on en
parle beaucoup on ne parle pas de la
guerre du Yémen aujourd'hui qui depuis
10 ans ravage ce pays F pas des maladies
qui ne qui avaient disparu ou des
enfants meurent de FA où le pays est
vraiment dans un état abominable c'est
probablement avec la République la RDC
un des pays les plus dur du monde la
démocratie oui vraiment et ça personne
n'en parle jamais on ne parle pas non
plus de ce qui se passe en Arménie où le
pays est menacé dans son intégrité
territoriale là ce n'est plus le carabak
qui a été qui a subi une épuration
ethnique c'est la République d'Arménie
qui est menacée dans son existence avec
des dictateurs comme aliaf et Erdogan
qui qui men tous les Arméniens et qui
veulent je les cite les chasser comme
desens on n' parle pas on ne parle pas
non plus des menaces de la Chine sur
Taïwan qui qui sont du même Akabi où
nous avons et j'oublie probablement des
conflits nous avons donc les les
dictateur une espèce d'internationale
des dictateurs contre les démocraties et
c'est ce qui se passe aussi en Israël et
c'est ce qui se passe aussi en Europe
d'une certaine façon quand on a Chypre
qui est qui est occupé depuis
1974 et les îles greces qui sont
menacées dans ce contexte vous allez me
dire dans ce contexte euh où vendredi 13
nous avons eu une des des djihadistes et
des terroristes qui ont demandé des
actions et ces actions ont été conduites
puisque nous pleurons aujourd'hui après
Samuel pati nous pleurons la mort d'un
professeur courageux à haras qui a été
assassiné par un enfant qui avait été
élevé en France logé nourri blanchi et
éduqué en France et qui est allé tuer
son un professeur dans le lycée où il
avait été éduqué et le de quelques jours
après et bien nous avons eu ces deux
pauvres supporters suédois qui ont été
assassinés à Bruxelles donc les paroles
comptent et quand le ministre de
l'Intérieur ce matin tient des promos
c'est pas n'importe qui je veux dire on
n'est pas dans une émission ou dans au
café du commerce et cetera on a le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui répond un
journaliste dans une émission politique
et qui parle de cette personne qui
mondialement connu puisque le foot c'est
mondialement connu en tenant des propos
qui sont graves Karine Benzema donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai dit
mais si c'est le cas je pense qu'il faut
aller plus loin parce qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas avoir de complaisance avec
le terrorisme maintenant j'entend que
Monsieur Benzema fait appel de cette
décision
et cette de ces propos pardon et
effectivement B on verra ce que la
justice dira aujourd'hui mais enfin on
on est dans un état de tension qui est
extrême et un ministre de l'Intérieur
qui dit ça pour une personnalité
pareille je pense qu'il faut aller
jusqu'au bout parce que non seulement ce
sont des grands champions mais en plus
ce sont des affluenceurs extrêmement
important vous êtes sûr que que Karim
Benzema a un lien avec les Frères
musulmans qu'il y a des preuves est-ce
qu'il y a des choses ou pas bah écoutez
moi je suis pas ministre de l'Intérieur
je ne suis pas enquêteur et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai interrogé le
le ministre de l'Intérieur et je lui ai
demandé alors où en est-on qu'est-ce qui
se passe si vous avez tenu ses propos il
faut pas enfin on peut pas Balan
excusez-moi de ce terme un peu triial de
tels propos sans aller jusqu'au bout de
la
démarche alors on a des outils
juridiques clairement aujourd'hui mais
par exemple on n a pas pour ce que
Gilles kpel a appelé le djihadisme
d'atmosphère aujourd'hui enfin néanmoins
moi ma seule interrogation c'était de
dire si si ce que vous dites si donc que
vous dites monsieur le ministre il faut
aller plus loin et ager une action pour
justement et bien faire en sorte que
cette personne ne puisse plus tenir ce
type de propos ou avoir des actions qui
menacent la sécurité des Français
puisque nous sommes en guerre contre le
terrorisme c'est pas moi qui le
dis et donc il faut aller plus loin si
donc ce qu'a dit le ministre de
l'Intérieur donc Karim Benzema donc il a
pas dit grandchose he pardonnez-moi he
si si non mais non mais il dit qu'il y a
des liens il dit je le suis depuis
plusieurs semaines et c'est notoire
oui qui surpr par Arab qui considè que
les frères musulans sont une
organisation terrorist ex c'est vraion
pas la France et j'espère que ce sera le
cas parce que vous j'imagine que comme
moi vous avez lu le livre de Madame
Florence berge blacker et il faut
absolument que toutes ces organisations
terroristes soient interdites en France
bien évidemment et j'espère que ce sera
bientôt le cas sur Karim benzem restons
alors ce qui surprend un peu c'est que
le ministre a été très loin alors est-ce
qu' il a effectivement ce qu'on appelle
en langage journalistique des billes
c'est des informations qu'il sortira un
peu plus tard et qui ou alors est-ce
qu'il s'est engagé sur un terrain un peu
aventureux on ne sait pas c'est vrai que
vous avez réagi très vite très très vite
moi ce qui m surprise oui vous demandez
la déchéance de français né en France
j'ai dit j'ai dit que oui mais c'est
c'est on a on a j'ai dit que on pouvait
toujours la demander parce que je pense
que
symboliquement dans la situation dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons si le
ministre de l'Intérieur raison je pense
que c'est des réflexions que nous devons
avoir parce que ce n'est pas possible
d'avoir aujourd'hui la situation en
France la situation mondiale la
situation en Europe on est quand même
presque 300 morts directes du terrorisme
chez nous on a je ne sais pas combien
d'actes antisémite par jour des menaces
vous-même vous parliez tout à l'heure
des menaces dont vous avez fait l'objet
on est nombreux malheureusement à faire
des à être victime de
menaces je pense que un moment donné il
faut aller plus loin et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je j'ai interrogé le
ministre de l'Intérieur pour lui dire
est-ce que vous avez vous AZ vous lu
demandé vous il faut aller plus
loin d'accord
interrogé çaté un défement cet
après-midi cet après-midi nous avons eu
des explications du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui dit bah oui j'ai dit ça
mais pour l'instant j'ai pas d'outil
donc moi j'ai toujours une petite
difficulté enfin une grosse difficulté
pardon de cette
litote quand on est un responsable
politique et
que on on dit quelque chose et qu'on
peut pas aller vers vers cette chose ça
crée quand même une confusion qui est
importante mais est-ce que est-ce que
Géral daranin Jacques cardose aurait dit
ça s'il n'avait aucune billeespère que
non j'ose espérer qu'il a des éléments
euh
c'est il laisse entendre il laisse
entendre dans son propos que il suit les
agissements de Monsieur Benzema depuis
un certain temps donc lui seul a entre
guillemets la main sur les service de
renseignement est-ce que vous trouvez
ici autour de la table je pose la
question aussi chez vous et vous valirez
aussi euh est-ce que vous trouvez il y
en a beaucoup qui disent aussi que c'est
disproportionné par rapport à la
réaction qu'a eu Karim Benzema sur les
réseaux est-ce que vous trouvez ça ou
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec les
gens qui disent au contraire c'est Karim
Benzema n'aurait pas dû faire ce genre
de publication et il y en a beaucoup
aussi qui disent voilà on trouve ça un
peu ça fait une affaire d'état est-ce
que c'est disproportionné pour vous
est-ce qu'il y en a qui trouvent ça
normal vous non mais moi ce que ce qui
me semble évident c'est que c'est un des
ténurs de l'équipe de France al l'équipe
de France elle c'était elle l'équipe de
France elle représente la France la
France est divisée donc je vois pas
pourquoi l'équipe de France échapperait
à cette division des esprits des raisons
et des cœurs entre deux camps qui
s'affrontent donc voilà ils ont ils sont
c'est pas une troupe qui marche comme ça
il moi je ne doute pas que des
informations j'espère en tout cas ça
serait grave ministère ministre de
l'Intérieur balancer des infos comme ça
aussi graves sans infos mais voilà ça
serait pas étonnant que l'équipe de
France soit aussi divisée que la
population donc donc oui
mais la déchance Naité vous AZ pas
répondu à ma questionoui c'est
disproportionnéah oui il faut mettre les
choses dans leur contexte tout parle
d'un tweet dans lequel Karim Benzema
soutient les civil palestinien à aucun
moment il dit qu'il ne soutient le Hamas
ce qui lui repré vous AZ rien
com
c'est de pas avoir un pour le
professeur pour qui s'est
pass parce qu'il n'a pas un mot qu'il ne
condamne pas c'est ça que je veux dire
et on fait des
RAC
choses nationalité mais elle a pas dit
ça alors on va revenir sur ce qu'a dit
Valérie s'il vous plaît 2 minutes de
petites secondes ce qu' arrêtez de
parler deséchéances de nationalité ce
que dit ce qu'a dit Valérie Boyer on le
répète c'est si ce qu' a dit girérard
daranin est confirmé elle demande une
déchéance de nationalité qu'on engage
qu'on engage il faut c'està dire qu'il
faut aller plus loin et qu'on réfléchiss
je veux dire c'est c'est c'est des
propos d'une extrême gravité que le
ministre de l'Intérieur a tenu sur une
personne dans le contexte dans lequel
nous sommes donc à un moment donné
on peut pas on peut pas être au milieu
du gay il faut aller plus loin justement
alors Raymond dis-nous toi est-ce que tu
trouves que c'est distion quel chose
avec les Frères musulmans ou quel qu'
soit puni par la loi on le punit par la
loi et on le sanctionne par la loi c'est
un enfant qui est né en France il est
français de naissance on va pas enlever
la nationalité il nationalité quoi après
il devient quoi pakistanais vient ça
c'est fait c'est le premier débat après
je r non non moi j'enlève pas la
nationalité de quelqu'un qui est en
France un enfant c'est pas pas quelqu'un
qui autre nation
de il
aéant des années en France à lon ça y
est ça on passe le tweet maintenant le
tweet je trouve que sil veut c'est bien
de de donner le soutien et la force à
Gaza et à la Palestine ce qui me dérange
moi comme vous avez dit tout à l'heure
c'est un influenceur c'est quelqu'un qui
est mondialement connu avec des millions
d'abonnés ce qui me dérange c'est que
tous les musulmans qui souffrent quand
il y a des attentats et on dit
toujoursut faut pas faire d'amalgam il
aurait pu faire un tweet pour dire je
condamne ce qui s'est passé en Belgique
parce que là c'est pas le Hamas c'est
pas la Palestine is pas Belgique non
mais non non mais excuse-moi excuse-moi
cé c'était après la Belgique là tu dis
des bêtis non il peut pourquoi il peut
pas faire de tweet là pour par là c'est
surtout le
professeuras alors le professeur et
aussi pour dire à tous les musulmans et
ti à tout que nous on dit pas d'amalgame
il faut dire aussi que lui qui a de la
puissance il pourrait dire je condamne
ce qui s'est passé en Belgique tous les
musulmans ne sont pas des terroristes
arrêtez de faire des amalgames il prend
pas position làdessus dire et c'est des
Suédois ça rien à voir avec le conflit
en Palestine Israël il aura pu prendre
position làdessus c'est ça que je
reproche qui s'est passé ça à voir avec
probablement les ordres qui ont été
donnés de faire du vendredi 13 une
journée du djihad je ve
direens vous allez loin ou mais c'est
d'accord j'ai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
compris
[Applaudissements]